I like white wine pinot grigio or white
zinfandel and I like something good
old-fashioned like Miller Lite currently
in Virginia if you want to buy hard
liquor you can't just go anywhere you've
got to go to a state owned and operated
store like this one that's because
Virginia is one of a handful of states
that not only regulates the sales and
distribution of liquor but actually owns
and operates all of the liquor stores in
its boundaries thankfully that's about
to change you know we got to be
innovative but we got a tough budget
we've got a historic downturn in the
economy at least in recent history and
we can't just do things the same ole way
we just can't accept the status quo this
isn't some garden-variety white
zinfandel enthusiasts this is bob
mcdonnell the new governor of virginia
certainly nothing that i gleaned from
the Constitution that would have me
think that it's better or required in
some way to have government control in
distilled spirits so well fiscal and
economic and philosophical perspective
it's it's the right thing to do not only
is it the right thing to do as recent
foundation economic policy analyst Lynn
Gilroy points out it's likely to be an
economic boon for the Old Dominion what
we found is that the states for instance
West Virginia Iowa and also Alberta
Canada is another example of a place
that once they privatized they were
actually able to increase revenue to the
state because what they're doing is
shifting from a essentially a monopoly
model to one in which private operators
in a regulated market are still
competing and they're paying license
fees you also have the the avoided cost
of the public employees and you know the
health benefits and the pensions and all
those things that go along with the
public employee well the state may raise
more money the real benefit will go to
consumers states and governments are
very bad at running businesses whether
you're talking about liquor stores
whether you're talking about a post
office whether you're talking about
parking operations and so what we find
is that they tend to be very poor at
matching supply with demand to go
does great job of a bunch of other
things running a liquor store
necessarily isn't one of them this is
prob serif a Virginia resident who knows
a lot about liquor stores in fact he
operates one in Washington DC where
stores are privately owned and operated
a Virginia ABC store doesn't really have
any ambiance talk for the customer they
don't have anything that jumps out at
you at the shelves but if you want
something that's a little more different
a little more unique you won't find it
as far as the look of them every single
one of them looks to be the same I think
our store offers all the things that the
ABC stores don't offer they offer an
ambiance they offer a shopping
environment you can spend an hour in
here looking at all the different things
because in Virginia if you want beer
wine and liquor you have to go to two
stores at least possibly three different
stores depending on you know how
selective you are and what you're
looking for in the beer or in the wine
but in DC you know if you're having a
party you can come in to one store and
you can get anything you want at that
store this guy's store had stuff I've
never seen anywhere before much less of
Virginia ABC store this is a bottle of
scotch that's seventeen thousand dollars
I guarantee you won't find it in
Virginia it's a fifty-five-year-old
mccowan it's an elite crystal decanter
there's 420 bottles of it in the world
not only is the selection better but
competition provides a direct incentive
for better customer service thank you
you're welcome how are you today we go
out of our way to make sure our
customers are paid attention to they
have any questions those questions are
answered if they want to order something
that we don't for whatever reason carry
that that it's or durable and it's
ordered for them in a timely manner we
deliver which is just another you know
like notch on her belt as for our
service is concerned if governor
McDonald's plan goes through Virginia's
liquor stores will become competitive
for the first time since Prohibition was
repealed and with that new competition
will come better service and better
selection that's the kind of approach
I'm going to take to government and hope
to if you interview me in a year I can
say look at how much less we're spending
in Virginia how much better people think
the services are and by the way it's
nice to be able to apply or distilled
spirits at the the local food line for
instance so you know we're working
towards all those goals and I'm excited
about it governor will gladly take you
up on that interview offer we'll bring
the questions you bring the white
zinfandel for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie
you